well there's a dating coach
well it's 35 years old and you've got a
dating coach
I mean at 35 don't you know how to date
or doesn't a dating coach tell you don't
take out your phone no you see this is
the problem like this is a red pill fact
so or basically like 100 of women want
20 of men so girls have been going
through their their 20s and their even
their early 30s like they're side chicks
yeah and so they've never really had any
relationship experience so they don't
know how to like vet men properly right
and so it's like they get to 35 and
they're still like mentally a teenager
because they've never had a real
relationship and so it's like yeah so
that's like what you see is she's
mentally still a teenager
there's a lot of them all out yeah
there's a lot I'm getting older and
that's why like you can't have a
conversation about like hate Sound about
happiness like that's an adult
conversation but like it's like you're
talking to teenagers but yeah but sooner
or later it's gonna bet it's itself out
the mental women ratio because they're
only going to realize that half of you
women are stupid we don't want you and
it's gonna even itself up and then
you're gonna end up lonely and barreling
with your dogs no that's what happens
yeah like I don't I don't see like I
don't see
her getting like saved unless like she
changes her behavior but like I just
don't see it happening because she
looked like here I'll keep up like even
me she's very dumb and Aaron yeah even
here I'll keep is your dating coach
married yes and she has a baby and her
wedding ring is at least five carats
yeah and her man is rich excuse me okay
you know what he herself makes like 30
to 50 Grand a month coaching women in
love
I mean good luck if that like works for
you I just like to me that sounds like
a 200k engagement ring like I think like
guys are gonna hear that and be like no
no no you just have to have the man
who's okay with maintaining you
right with maintaining you right like
you can be high maintenance but if you
are dating a man that is okay with
maintaining you you're fine you're not
high maintenance then you're just on
their level
okay but I'm just thinking like like
I I know but those guys that are making
like like that amount of money like
yeah like I think they typically want
like the young like 21 22 year olds
what I'm 30. so I'm not that old I'm
actually no I don't have an age to be
wiped up by somebody who's like in their
40s and like ready to be serious and
start popping out babies a 21 year old
unless you're Kylie Jenner is
realistically too young to be like
popping out kids
like you're too young
yeah I mean this is just I'm sorry the
200 000 like that's crazy to me I was a
lot nicer than these people have tried
but she's just even like there's
something living in her she's scary look
at her she looks possessed she's not
right no seriously she's like yeah she's
got no no no no she's just ain't no that
reminds me of she right there when she
was talking
my niece
and my niece is about uh seven eight I'm
just gonna get me this my dad's gonna
get me that this is what that's what she
said
they're mentally like like kids oh my
friend's got a ring like that so I'm
gonna get a ring like that and if she
can get one then I can
and that's where she's going on she
showed me what her like friend looked
like
her friend was hot like I'm sorry you
get hot girl privilege
like I I just think a lot of times girls
that are like fives take advice from
girls that are eight but the eights can
get away with [ __ ] the fives can't you
said that
she's single yeah she's never in the day
is she a virgin
she's an undercover her
that's my mommy's calling oh probably
she's an undercover because what else
because all she's doing is horroring
herself after the highest bidder yeah I
mean what else has she been doing for
the last decade like you've had 10 years
plus working our way up to sleep in the
way up to the top but she's never gonna
get there but that's that's the thing is
like she's like a five she's probably
sleeping with eight but that's that's
what I'm saying the Modern Woman is a
side chick
maybe he's going to look at her for a
bit of fun yeah that's what I'm saying
the modern because she thinks that she's
eye candy she's not eye candy no
no
I can't get 30.
no sir you can be eye candy at 30 if
you're dating a 60 year old yeah you're
eye candy because I don't think he's an
older guy I never really just I wasn't
feeling good about myself at that time
he was a fantastic man and somebody goes
to me Jennifer why you got up such an
older man
because I'm always going to look better
than a woman his age
that's right which is true it made me
feel good for a while you know and
that's what it was is that I was feeling
bad about myself and like compared to a
woman these days I'm gonna I'm always
gonna look good but
it was just childish I don't even think
she'll date that old either
that's like
oh my gosh I cannot believe that's crazy
someone that can make that amount of
money in a shorter period of time like
somebody who would say a musical artist
right a YouTube producer somebody who's
in entertainment somebody who's on a TV
show somebody who does like concerts and
tours that amount of money isn't the
same to them you know what I mean
what do you mean like say I was dating
somebody like a pretty easy right okay
he makes 150 000 minimum per show
minimum that's what he makes in a show
yeah so if he does a couple shows the
200 Grand to him he won't even feel it
now let me let me show you g-eazy's
ex-girlfriend let me just because she
she said G-Eazy hey asleep
this is who she's talking about if she
was to date a G-Eazy that's his
ex-girlfriend
I know that like the raw I know like the
the like that's not a good look like the
way she dresses but like she's stunning
like that is a stunning girl and you you
think you're yeah he's not even he's is
he a star yeah he's a star that's what
I'm saying I'm saying like he's not even
huh I wouldn't even she the girls are
yeah yeah but I'm saying that guy can
get girls like that you're not gonna
have the same results why would you want
her this is something coming from
someone like I've been in a relationship
with a guy that was worth over a million
like I I but I would never know
200k on a ring
like to me that's like that's almost
like entitled like I'm not entitled to
his money I mean
here's the thing I can afford it myself
I I would want you to be able to get it
for me right yeah get it myself
wow oh my gosh that's just
yeah I guess like we kind of probably
have different like spending habits
because to me I'm like I would even if I
had the money I would never spend that
on a ring
like this is she's serious she is dead
serious but I'm also not that much of a
jewelry person right so it's like you're
not gonna need to be buying me diamonds
for every anniversary or jewelry all the
time like get me my ring
and that's it I don't really need much
else
oh gosh sorry
hi Nikki I just added you to it
purposely not putting your camera on get
me
I mean if you spent 200 calories I hope
I hope he gets you nothing ever again
200k like what the [ __ ] you don't you
know I don't if you want something by
yourself love if you can't buy yourself
why are you gonna expect somebody else
to buy for you 200k ring
hook up
no I have to like connect it to the
thing hold on I've done like a YouTube
live with her she's smart
oh well
we'll go in a minute sorry
I can I can drop you if this is a bad
time I just thought I'd add you to the
chat no just real quickly because we got
dinner and lamb and all this other good
stuff listen this I love this life this
is hilarious
because I love you but the girls are
asking for 300K diamond rings and
everything on this floor these guys are
now saying that women hit the wall at
age 20. and you're talking about the two
hundred thousand dollar examine they'll
be like oh God
but you guys are both women they're both
women so you really don't know
no but like being around is being just
like a lot of these men they seem like
they're in la la land ourselves and it's
like the people that they're talking
about is like who are you meeting so if
two people are coming with completely
different expectations and like when you
were saying earlier you have pointed out
the person that was in the yoga class
she had a 300 000 ring the person your
coach she has a 300 000 ring it wasn't
like based the reason the ring that I
have I wanted it because of the fact
that growing up some there's no certain
type of thing in my family that that's
what it was but it wasn't because any of
my friends had that ring I couldn't care
less what they had so no I don't want it
because they have it I know I can have
it because they have it do you
understand what I'm saying like I
understand that oh
eight to Grass because I've
I've associate with people who have
these things they're in my Circles of
people they're in my friend groups
and I know I can have it because I've
seen it not it's not funny because they
have it I want it and then I've seen it
I've seen validation of it in my in
front of my face